good afternoon I am Jean Townsend black
and I am representing Yale University
Press on behalf of the Terry lectures it
is with pleasure that I welcome you to
the fourth election I keep tunson who is
Dwight H Terry lecturer in a series that
is celebrating its a hundred and seventh
year as an endowed lectureship and has
provided since 1923 not only lecturers
but also books from preeminent scholars
in religion the sciences and philosophy
to address ways in which science and
philosophy inform religion and religions
application to human welfare
Keith Thompson's lectures have been
addressing the topic Jefferson and
science Jefferson and Darwin science and
religion in troubled times yesterday we
were regaled with vivid recounting of
the nature of the debates reports or
correspondence generated after Darwin's
Origin of Species was published in
particular those occurring in Boston
which involved Louis Agassiz ASA gray
and William Barton Rogers in an Oxford
those that engaged Bishop Samuel
Wilberforce Thomas Henry Huxley and
Joseph Hooker among others it has been
stimulating to listen to Keith develop
various themes among them changes in
authority the strong personalities and
resistance to or acceptance of change as
scientific advances introduced to new
ideas or altered current thinking or
both I began to wonder just how many of
the lectures from the first one
delivered in 1923 used the key words
evolution Darwin or Jefferson in their
titles so last night refreshed my
acquaintance with them no surprise
evolution is the frontrunner with seven
appearances Darwin scores one and
Jefferson
the distribution over time and the
lecturers themselves are food for
thought
the first lecturer John Arthur Thompson
delivered his lectures in nineteen
twenty three twenty four and they were
entitled concerning evolution they were
followed by Robert Andrew Milliken
1926-27 on evolution in science and
religion the next usage crops up in
nineteen forty eight forty nine when
George Gaylord Simpson gave his lectures
the meaning of evolution followed by
Margaret Mead in 1957-58 on continuities
in cultural evolution and then Stephen
Jay Gould in 1985-86 on Darwin and dr.
Dolittle Walter J Goering in 1993-94 on
master control genes and development in
evolution
Francisco Ayala in 2011 on from biology
to ethics and evolutionist view of human
nature and David Sloan Wilson in 2004 on
evolution for everyone so we are
breaking new ground this time with the
addition of Thomas Jefferson this
lecture stint however is not Keith's
first brush with the Terry lectures for
the volume that celebrated the Terry
lectures Centennial which is entitled
the religion and science debate why
doesn't continue Keith very kindly
provided an introduction I would like to
dedicate this final lecture to Professor
Leo Hickey who has served as a member of
the Terry lectures committee for many
years and who first proposed Keith for
these lectures it is regrettable that
Leo has been unable to attend the
lectures in person but we all owe him
our gratitude for having advocated
Keith's nomination as the lecturer in
closing Leo and Keith have special roles
for me personally and professionally I
first met Keith as a very junior editor
at a previous publisher Academic Press
where I was introduced to him when he
was invited to come for a science book
brainstorming session with a group of
editors in about 1979 or 1980 I met Leo
not long after arriving at Yale
University Press in 1990 he was a
science faculty member on the
publication's committee then and it
seems that Leo with was Keith immediate
successor on that committee
because Keith served in this capacity
for the press in the 1980s Leo was a
wise and thoughtful first publications
committee member for me to have
encountered and an energetic advocate
for the science publishing program
another association for me is Keith's
writing of the marginalia column for
American scientist magazine and a
selection of those essays became the
basis for one of the earliest books I
acquired for the press the common but
less frequent loon and other essays
those essays celebrated the aesthetic
literary and intellectual aspects of
science and what is involved in being a
scientist a great intellectual adventure
let's now continue the intellectual
adventure as we learn about science
religion and the contest for authority
could I please remind everyone to turn
off or silence all cell phones and that
at the close of this lecture there will
be an opportunity for questions there
are mics up here at the front we
encourage you to come use them and there
will also be a reception in room 108
please join us there thank you
Jean Thompson black it's always been a
bit of a confusion in fact in each of my
books that I've had the great pleasure
of working on with Jean in the
acknowledgments I always have to write
Jean Thompson black brackets no relation
close the brackets because it wouldn't
be good to have your daughter editing
all your books but you know it's been
going on for so long I'm actually
seriously thinking about adopting her
now it's a great pleasure to be back in
New Haven Linda and I have have walked
around as we always do when we come here
because you can't park anywhere and it's
really extraordinary how you can be
walking one place and it's exactly the
same as it was when I left here in 87 or
when I arrived here a few years before
that and then you'll turn a corner and
you'll see Yale's contribution to the
fiscal rebuilding of the United States
it's very much like people used to say
about the London School of Economics in
its growth phase in the 1950 yell has
become the Empire upon which the cement
never sets
but Giamatti when its president used to
say the only way you could make money in
New Haven was buying in it being an
expert in repairing slate roofs he of
quite he inherited all the deferred
maintenance problems of previous
administrations it seems now that
somebody has a pretty good line going in
bright blue plastic and if it's any of
you a contribution would be greatly
accepted anyway enough of that it is a
great pleasure and an honor to be asked
to give these lectures and the theme of
these talks has been to use a number of
narratives to exemplify the changing
relationship
between science and religion over the
last 200 250 years and I began by
emphasizing the role of the individual
everything starts with the individual
and then from the individual slowly as
new science new information is developed
it becomes incorporated in to or
rejected by authority but it all starts
with the individual Jefferson's
intellectual struggles with geology for
instance Darwin's difficulties with
religion and in the last lecture
yesterday using the example of the
Darwinian debates I developed a theme
that these conflicts between science and
religion that we see all the time
whether they're intellectual personal or
institutional however they begin end up
not being simply about philosophy
science or theology alone or in
combination but about a contest for
authority the conflict between science
and religion then it's really a small
part of a much more general broader
phenomenon which it happens whenever new
information bumps into conventional
thinking and institutional Authority and
inevitably those to the development of
new knowledge and the attitudes of
institutions and authority always change
at different rates and when they change
at different rates there is bound to be
difference and conflict so let me start
today by just reminding us that science
and religion are not that well religion
is not the only place where there's an
impact for science over the years also
there has been a considerable the
interesting relationship between science
and the arts and the humanities and I
want to start by reading to you as a
short passage it seems that in 1838 the
year that he finally put together the
bits
made up the theory of evolution by
natural selection Darwin had been
reading Wordsworth and he sat down in
his notebooks a series of questions
about the problem of assessing beauty
and particularly his own response to
scenery music poetry and pictures and
then he wrote this fascinating entry I a
geologist have an ill-defined notion of
land covered with ocean that he means
the bottom of the ocean
former animals slow force cracking the
surface and truly poetical brackets see
Wordsworth about science being
sufficiently habitual to become poetical
and then eight years later there's
another notebook reference to Wordsworth
and to an essay by Burke on the sublime
at the end of Burke's essay on the
sublime and beautiful there are some
notes and likewise on Wordsworth
dissertation on poetry so I took these
to a friend of mine who is an expert on
Wordsworth and he he laughed and said I
will of course that's easy he's
referring to the preface to the lyrical
ballads and you all know that anyway of
1802 and this is the bit I want to read
you because I think it's just
fascinating
here's Wordsworth writing about what
effect science might have and I'm gonna
have to be careful with this if the
labors of men of science should ever
create any material revolution direct or
indirect in our condition and in the
impressions which we habitually receive
the poet will then sleep no more than at
present but he will be ready to follow
the steps of the man of science not only
in those general indirect effects but he
will be at his side and will welcome the
being thus produced as a dear and
genuine inmate of the household of man
and become part of the atmosphere of
sensation in which we all move our wings
and create a material
revolution direct or indirect in our
condition so here is the poet saying
there's all this science stuff on the
horizon and it could work out well and
if it does we'll embrace it so two
hundred years later two hundred and ten
it seems that we've come a long way
towards the familiarization and
habituation of science to make that
material revolution in our condition now
whether it's become as Darwin wondered
poetical is a very different question
but there's no doubt that it has science
as completely and irrevocably changed
the whole atmosphere in which quote we
all move our wings so it's all change
wherever you go you find there is change
and in the mandate for the Terry
lectures which you may have read Dwight
Terry specifically mentions evolution
and evolution of course is the
archetypal change but if you think about
evolution with a small E it's it's
essentially contingent change contingent
change being changed dependent on what
already was before and what happens in
the future will be contingent on what
there is now and if you think of
evolution in that simple term then
virtually all change in society is
evolution of some sort true revolution
change out of nothing is that turns out
to be rather difficult to find there are
some and there are changes negative
changes that is directly in opposition
to something else but most change turns
out to be contingent and everything
changes and God has evolved some years
ago I'm just trying to irritate you here
just
so sometimes they get years ago I was
flying across the United States reading
a very interesting book by a man called
Jack miles and you may know this book
and at some point I put it down on the
seat and went to the back of the plane
and when I came back this pretty young
stewardess I think she would have been
in those days now a flight attendant had
the book in her hands and she said this
is interesting what is it about God a
biography what could that possibly mean
well it's a very very interesting
question she didn't mean I don't think
she meant who is God what she meant was
how could God have a biography what what
changes about God well it's fascinating
book by Jack Myles if you read the Bible
and it's a very long book he traces book
by a book of the Bible how God changes
basically from someone a tyrant occupy
preoccupied by sex and death to the God
of love and forgiveness of the New
Testament
so God's biography going to Jack and now
there have been several other books
there's one called the evolution of God
on the same theme it's really quite
interesting
so what else changes in the religious
world which might seem to be sort of
monolithic but if you look at it lots of
things have changed perhaps one of the
most interesting ones is that it's a
pity you know that there weren't any
public opinion polls in in Jefferson's
time or even Darwin's time which so we
only have to guess but I think we can be
pretty sure that this number has dropped
only thirty to forty percent of people
in the general population of the United
States believe that the god is lit that
the Bible is literally the Word of God
fifty percent think it's inspired but
not literally true in Jefferson's time
the thinking number thinking it was
literally true would have been close to
a hundred percent there are dozens of
outfits that do public opinion polls at
the moment and some of the best ones are
by the Pew Center for religion and
public life
and the Gallup Organization and the
Barna Group and they all show that at
the moment in the United States
somewhere between 85% and 92% of the
population
believe in God or a universal spirit and
a similar number maybe a little bit less
80 to 85% believe that God was the
creator of the universe who rules the
world today that was the question they
were asked not just the Creator but who
rules the world today and approximately
the same number see God is personally
concerned with each of us now these
numbers as polls go by change all the
time
one thing that's changed a great deal is
that while 75 to 80 percent peep of
people in the United States express a
belief in heaven that's not the same as
fewer than the number who believe in God
but still 75 to 80 percent of Christians
believe Express a belief in heaven only
60 percent think that hell is a physical
place only 40 percent see Satan as
anything less than a symbol and here's
the most surprising thing only 35
percent see the Holy Spirit is a real
entity rather than a symbol well these
are huge changes since say 1900 and I
have to say since the significant
changes since I was a small boy as I
remember well from listening to my
father's sermons now as scientists one
of the things that irritates scientists
most and if it doesn't it should his
miracles if this was a thorn in the side
of Hume Thomas Paine Jefferson as well
and every one of the heroes of the age
of reason today 80% of the population
believe in miracles you'll see in a
moment where I'm going with these
statistics and as seventy-two percent
believe that angels are real phenomenon
now when I first read these statistics I
thought this
this can't be right so I conducted a
little survey and I invite you to do
exactly the same thing I went to our
local Borders bookshop part of the
change includes extinction and there is
no longer a borders bookshop anywhere
and now you're going to have to go to
Barnes & Noble so gonna go to Barnes &
Noble and pace out the number of shelf
feet devoted to science
then pace out the number of shelf feet
devoted to religion then pace out the
number of shelf feet devoted to
alternative religions and then pace out
the number of shelf feet devoted to
angels you will be amazed so what about
scientists well the Pew people did a
study of the American Association of
advancement of science and they
discovered that 31 33 % of all
scientists believe in God and another 18
percent believe in a universal spirit
which adds up to a slight majority of 51
percent so you look at these numbers and
you say why aren't us our people on the
religious side worried about science
they're doing very well indeed and
science is not doing very well in these
polls for instance only 40% of the
population believe that except I should
say that humans evolved rather than were
created 60% think that a worldwide flood
accounts for all geological I'm the
parent repellant a logical record over
the last few years only 18% think the
world's it's longer is older than 10,000
years and fifty percent of the
population thinks that the earth was
created in six literal days I'm not
making this up this is what the polls
say now these polls get repeated and
what's interesting is that in the last
ten years you can see a steady but
significant retreat
these numbers two lower numbers just as
they represent retreat from say 1900 but
the numbers are accelerating in the past
20 years the number of people who
thought religion to be important in
public life has decreased from 88
percent to 80 now these are numbers for
America if you ask the same question in
Europe the number of people who think is
significant is actually 20 percent
there's something very interesting about
the American situation especially to a
foreigner from Europe the proportion of
people attending church in the United
States he's always given it somewhere
around 40 percent but a recent study was
done by some people called Haddaway and
Marla in the journal for the scientific
study of religion which shows that the
number is actually half that 20% and
they suggest that all of these numbers
are actually exaggerated by about a
factor of two because people don't want
to give the wrong answer as it were to
that toll people I'm going to continue
with these statistics for a moment I
hope you don't mind but formal
intellectual point of view one of the
most disparity things about these
surveys is a result that the Pew survey
got in 2010 only 63 percent of the
American population knew the name of the
first book of the Bible it's Genesis by
the way it just went to fewer than 50%
of Roma Catholics knew the name of all
four of the Gospels I I just find this
just incredibly depressing what is wrong
I don't it's not a fault of religion
surely it's a fault of our whole
evolutionary I mean educational system
I'm sorry it there's something really
wrong with this educational system and
if we don't all know what the Bible says
how can we all have an opinion about it
pro or con I personally think that
educator that religions should be
taught much more openly in schools in
America as it is in England and I would
love to see religion debated under the
same terms that the creationists
currently say evolution bit should be
debated that is teach the controversy
with that a power between those two be
interesting I think it would so here is
an interesting situation it looks as
though on the religion side there's not
much to worry about people in this
country are very happy with their
situation so why is it that the
religious side if you can don't mind
think of it as a side versus the other
side which is really not very
intellectually appropriate but it's
convenient why do why does the religious
side continue to be so worried about
science well and this is obvious in one
way because religion finds itself under
attack by people like Richard Dawkins
for instance my former college my former
colleague at Oxford but it's not just
that religion science is coming under
will under attack from both Christians
and Muslims and these attacks are not
just directed at the teaching of
evolution in schools but also for us
reasons that I find still quite
difficult to understand for the teaching
of global climate change and I'm sure
this isn't going to be the end of the
list and it seems to me and I may be
wrong that it could only reflect a
general anti intellectualism a real fear
of progressive thinking a fear of the
unknown that would have been perfectly
familiar to Thomas Jefferson in the
election of 1800 when he was attacked
for being an intellectual and thinking
into in progressive terms progress was
thought to be in those days by the
Federalists to be extraordinarily
dangerous but it's also true that
science continues to reach evermore into
the realms of the religious world
and into things like human behavior and
in human behavior things like morality
and ethics and that all started with
Darwin he wrote in The Descent of Man a
lot about how you could explain even the
religious sense that there is a God in
terms of essentially conditioning of
children by parents and ethics and moral
in terms of a sort of enlightened as
self-interest of parts of groups of
populations and so on I'll come back to
that in a moment so going back to
Wordsworth and the world in which we
will move our wings one of the most
dramatic changes of the last century has
been the insertion of science into all
publics all aspects of public and
private life and particularly into
government as government attempts to act
for the most good for the most people
and creates a very it creates a very
different philosophy of society than in
Jefferson's time where Jefferson thought
we should all be a nation of yeoman
farmers it enlist science and technology
and everything from medicine Public
Health the environment the management of
Natural Resources Public Works
communications and of course military
applications
there seems to be no part of public life
that is not driven in large part by
science now in the decades after the
Second World War and right through the
time that I was a graduate student and
young faculty member here at Yale so
let's say that the mid 60s
people worried a great deal about this
intrusion of science into government
there was a fear that science would take
over government in an anti-democratic
way science became to be a sort of a
bogeyman and people worried about this a
lot and then as the time went by it
seemed less of a bogeyman and the
situation rather perhaps threw in
inertia calmed down
it was discovered that science would not
end up giving undue authority to the
executive or legislative branch
but the continuing problem would be
whether they would use their scientific
authority responsibly um so by and large
we've reached this sort of shifting
balance between how science and
government should interact with each
other and nobody at the moment is
writing a lot of books on science and
government as they were in in the 1960s
I think people have come to understand
the world is infinitely complex and the
parts are so complicatedly interrelated
that you need scientific methods to make
any sense of them at all but as I said
everything continues to change and one
of the most significant developments of
recent years is not the intrusion of
science into government but ironically
enough the intrusion of a religiously
based politics into government and we
have certainly seen that for instance in
the recent primary campaigns over the
last six months so it appears that the
worries that people had with respect to
science and religion and government have
sort of shifted polarity now we have to
worry about the religious side because
not because it
urges people to a more moral and caring
life but where it is sufficiently
retrogressive in ways that they do not
appear in mr. Terry's terms to produce a
broadened or purified religion which is
what he wanted his lectures to produce
so this rolls us all the way back to the
question of the conflict between science
and religion and one of the first
questions to ask is is there necessarily
a conflict between the two must there
always be a conflict between the two and
the first answer which is the academics
answer is well that's the wrong question
because there are too many different
kinds of science and there are too many
different kinds of religion if you ask
historians particularly historians of
religion is there necessarily a conflict
between science religion they will
almost all say no and they think that
their lesser brethren by which they mean
the historians of science like me have
fallen into the trap of what they call a
naive myth of nessa of inevitability
that it makes a good story to say that
science and religion must inevitably be
in conflict but that they really aren't
and they have a good argument against
this they point out the long periods in
history where all the scientists were
clerics so how could they be in conflict
except of course it was those very
scientific clerics like Copernicus who
created all the trouble now I call this
the flat tire hypothesis the situation
is perfectly fine it's just at the
bottom that the tire is flat
so scientists were clerics and there was
no conflict except where the rubber met
the road and then there was a lot of
conflict and it's it's sort of
nonsensical anyway because science is so
different from what it was then then
science was allied with magic and
astronomers including Copernicus
carefully religiously so-to-speak
calculated horoscopes Newton was
preoccupied preoccupied by alchemy now
you can explain all of those things
for instance horoscopes were a logical
extension of Ptolemaic theory and so on
well the second answer is that yes the
conflict does seem to be inherent and
ongoing where it is based in differences
that necessarily challenge your
authority and this goes back to where I
was before but it's the very nature of
science to produce new information and
to be challenging all the time and it
turns out that we really don't want our
authorities to change all that quickly
now we're very happy for instance if
there's new information at the EPA or
the Centers for Disease Control will
change their authority instantly but
where the religious side the philosophy
esophagus of science I'd uphold the
eternal verities that are not restricted
to
any particular religion you can find for
instance in Aristotle's ethics then we
don't want the authority to change so
this is we get into a difficult
situation here but where matters a
practice and dogma affect a changing
society
for instance in subjects like
contraception we can fairly expect more
adaptability on all sides than we
currently have at the moment now there
are two other possible approaches to
dealing with this conflict between
science and religion one is to realize
except perhaps that science and all
facts are really illusory there are only
strongly held opinions the postmodern
constructivist sort of approach then
science isn't so threatening and there
are several people who have written very
seriously about this this is a solution
to the conflict between science and
religion but of course it only works if
religion is also a series of very
closely held opinions rather than fact
and so both sides would have to give in
and it's very hard for me to see which
side would blink first so perhaps the
most popular model for trying to
reconcile science and religion and we're
getting towards the end now is is what
you might call the independence model
now in these talks I've tried very hard
to introduce quotations from important
people called Thompson and I want to now
tell you a section from a sermon by
Samuel H Thompson in a sermon in Hanover
college as it was then in New Hampshire
in 1856 when you desire to know what God
has revealed to us by his Spirit look to
the Oracle of God look not to science or
to nature they are indeed full of truth
and that to which is God's truth with
which you cannot to carefully store your
minds but they are not the truths of
Revelation and can never in foul
direct your eyes to them nor take their
place and I'll read from another sermon
you won't be surprised that this is the
sermon by the great Reverend Pusey in
which he accused Darwin of having
written a quasi theology in the Origin
of Species 1978 some Mary's 1878 some
Mary's Church Oxford the basis of a
lasting peace and alliance between
physical science and theology is that
neither should intrude into the province
of the other this is also true science
for Sciences certain knowledge based on
certain effects facts on which theology
rests our spiritual facts those of
physical science are material now in
modern terms this is often expressed as
science and religion being two different
ways of knowing religion is the
authority for a spiritual moral world
full of reverence obligation and purpose
and leading to a final eternal
Redemption by God's son for science it
is the material world given by
Democritus his chance and necessity
which I mentioned earlier and that ends
with the son s UN petering out some five
billion years or so by which time
evolutionary events will have totally
transformed life on Earth anyway so
those are the two sides the two
different ways of knowing now you all
know of the late Stephen Jay Gould he
was a great pal of mine now and again we
depended on how irritatingly pompous
either of us was being at a particular
moment but basically we got on very well
and I think it was because he was a very
nice man with the best of peacemaking
ambitions that he took this hoary old
idea of the separation between science
and religion and dressed it up with a
new term describing the two as
non-overlapping magisteria
n OMS and Wheaton was the same as pew
ZZZ and everybody else to demonstrate
this since they
distinct subjects they ought to coexist
peacefully apart now professor Martin
here at Yale said the other day quite
reasonably science and religion can be
seen as separate discourses it is not
the job of Christian theology to
question string theory and that's
perfectly true and science can say
nothing about the basics of a belief in
God or in Christ as a personal Savior
that is simply outside the realm of
science okay therefore you might think
that apart from a few zealots in terms
of basic philosophy each side should
leave the other side alone but
unfortunately I have to tell you that a
rigid application of goulds
non-overlapping magisteria
while it's a good example of what i
discussed earlier with saving the
phenomenon is a bit like Cinderella's
sister trying to put their feet into the
glass slipper the conflict between
religion and science exists in my
opinion not just with respect to debates
about the nature and the existence of
God or the validity of any scientific
idea but precisely because the
magisteria the claims of authority of
science and religion do in fact overlap
intersect and compete with each other
and that's good news which I will now
explain going back by the 19th century
the facts of science that invaded
theological territory by Cathedral mad
amount they degraded biblical authority
concerning the origin and the age of the
earth the nature of the book of Genesis
itself science seriously can questions
any supernatural involvement in the
origin of life demonstrates a lack of
such involvement in the diversification
of life it denies a universal flood it
shows how it cannot possibly have
happened but it also demonstrates that
there was at just about the right moment
a local flood in the Levant which
corresponds to the biblical flood and
also the built the flood mentioned in
Gilgamesh and other
fables and so on science gives you a
whole different view of the origin of
future evolution of the cosmos science
does not afford humans a an exceptional
supernaturally derived place in the
evolution of life and as I had mentioned
early it's seriously engaged in attempts
to show that features such as a moral
sense and even a religious sense have an
evolutionary origin in some version of
enlightened groups self-interest so
these are all subjects where various
religions claim an authority largely
sometimes wholly consequence on the base
of some sort of divine Revolution or
accepted teaching and it's very frankly
very hard to see where any accommodation
could be made to defect to dilute the
effects of science here and that's no
doubt why the idea of the separation
that non-overlapping magisteria is so
appealing and so dangerous but as the TV
ads say but wait there is more
along with your steak knives a far more
interesting question about these
magisteria arises from the overlaps and
the conflicts that arise from science
having made recent advances into areas
where no clear-cut and explicit
religious authority has existed whether
in Jefferson's time or Darwin's or even
fifty years ago what could I possibly
mean there that where religious tenets
lack a deep theological foundation
having only broad generalities to rep
Egypt revelation for their
pronouncements now that's fighting words
these are the phenomena in the moral
ethical sphere all the bioethical issues
biotechnology stem cells cloning genetic
engineering ownership of cell lines and
practical issues such as the economics
the rationing of health care stewardship
of the environment nuclear power global
nuclear war global climate change
and indeed everybody's favorite
contraception these are issues that
don't concern theological abstractions
do not involve the supernatural but
conduct concern the conduct of daily
life where science has an immediate as
well as a principle impact they say a
great deal about how we act as humans
but nothing about whether God created us
or even anything about evolution
there is nothing I tell you I can take
this up in the discussion if you like
but there is really nothing in the Bible
or 2,000 years of subsequent revelation
to really defend in my opinion why
churches are against contraception and I
can get into that later but I don't want
to take too much of time but I can't
emphasize enough that these are these
there is this range of issues where both
religion and science have ownership it's
like the sign that's in the antique shop
but if you broke it you own it well if
you made it in the sense of being a
scientist in developing say for new
forms of contraception or in vitro
fertilization then that isn't something
that the scientist can put down on the
table anymore and say well you deal with
that now that was the way science was
say maybe 50 years ago but now where
science made it science owns it and so
both sides have some ownership and so
they're issues where if matters of
doctrinal issues and prejudice can be
put aside they ought to be where
religion and science can in fact come
together they can come together because
the supposedly non-overlapping
magisteria
overlap in these wonderfully interesting
ways so you'll think well okay can this
really happen well it's already
happening in the area of environmental
stewardship and there's a lovely thing
in today's New York Times I bless them
for always producing something that
supports something I was going to say
the communica patriarch of the
Orthodox Church Constantinople has
announced that for all Orthodox
believers crimes against the environment
lack of care misuse of the environment
is not just folly but is in fact a sin
he is essentially put out a fatwa
against environmental polluters this is
the first time that any church has done
that although the the Catholic Church
and other churches have come very close
but this is really quite an interesting
development but on a more mundane level
let me just tell you about a meeting
that was held on May the 25th of last
year 2011 when a very interesting group
of people got together in the town where
I live Philadelphia to talk about an
environmental issue and this was a very
interesting combination of people as you
would expect there were representatives
of the Sierra Club physicians industry
of course unions environmental groups
and private citizens but also the
rabbinate the Catholic Church
Evangelical Protestant groups and
Methodists these groups could unite not
on broad sweeps of dogma and philosophy
but on a common interest in power
station emissions this is exactly what I
meant by the non-overlapping magisteria
having these wonderful overlapping
regions and that is where we ought to be
able to get together now I would love to
end on this positive note but she'll be
surprised I'm sure that actually and
quite pessimistic about that because
this conflict between science and
religion on quasi philosophical points
that have nothing to do with the conduct
of our lives are coming back into the
fore again well I guess they do have to
do with the conduct of our lives but
they're not not deeply philosophical and
I only have to remind you of
contributions of two congressmen during
the last election campaign
congressman Todd akin of Missouri
famously reported that the female body
has mechanisms that operates so that
rape can't result in pregnancy
Congressman Paul Broun of Georgia
running unopposed I might add said that
evolution embryology I'm not embryology
I don't get that anyway
evolution embryology and the Big Bang
Theory are quote lies straight from the
pit of hell meant to convince people
that they do not see need a savior yeah
why do we care about that
they're both members of the House
Committee on Science Space and
Technology so doing good hands folks
with all state so I'm just going with
one last twitting of my theological
friends there isn't Kentucky as I
mentioned in my first lecture something
called the Creation Museum and there was
a philosophy behind the Creation Museum
and it was expressed in a letter to the
New York Times which I will quote the
people creating the exhibits of the
Creation Museum accepting the Bible as
God's literal truth doesn't mean that we
discount science it does mean that we
interpret science from the biblical
viewpoint evidence isn't labeled with
facts and dates we arrive at conclusions
about the unobservable past based on our
pre-existing beliefs it's hard to think
of a more unscientific philosophy if you
want to call it than that now
this allows them to create in Kentucky
and soon in Florida and soon after that
in Texas really quite popular museums
devoted to creation in which the world
is 6,000 years old and because you have
to account for dinosaurs presumably
having been wiped out of the flood there
would have been a time where dinosaurs
and humor
co-existed and so there are large
diorama exhibits with dinosaurs and
people wandering around together and
there is a biblical justification for
this and I'm sure some of you know what
it is these supposed dinosaurs they beat
him off job 40 verse 15 and Leviathan
job 41 1 2 34 they've interpreted be him
off and Leviathan as dinosaurs now every
theological scholar for years has
wondered what BM often live out
somewhere and clearly they're partly the
crocodile and hippopotamus which were -
most feared beasts with the lion of the
Levant of biblical times and they're
partly also mythical untamable beasts
summoned out of the folkloric depths to
symbolize the power of God now luckily
we can read the book of Job for
ourselves and see if the book of Job
which is not my favorite book of the
Bible let's face this only a folk
narrative of it isn't a folk narrative
God really is despicable and what he did
I was unconscionable so let's move on
before we get stuck in that we can read
the rest of Jobe the same chapter 41
verses 19 to 21 description of Leviathan
out of his mouth go burning lamps and
sparks of fire burn leap out out of his
nostrils goeth smoke as of a seething
pot or caldron his breath kindless coals
and a flame going out goeth out of his
mouth this is a dragon this is a comic
book
this is Hagar the horrible if you read
the Sunday papers now confronted with
this sort of insult to science and I
have to say to the museum profession
most people just give a deep sigh oh
it's just those guys and they hope it'll
all
we'll die a natural death but I want to
tell you that I think that's far too
relaxed a response dinosaurs and job is
not just a piece of ignorant foolishness
it's a highly calculated flagship
challenge to the world of science and a
raw contest for yet again Authority so
what's to be done unfortunately we live
an age when this sort of thing thrives
so who speaks for science science is
kind of disorganized and nonconformist
when it comes to having a particular
view on things there really aren't a lot
of bishops and Pope's in science the
rational viewpoint and of course
scientists always claim the high ground
is danger in danger being left behind in
a rush of politico-religious jockeying
for authority so in the face of the
shrill insistence that currently in fest
so much of the world what is the
solution
well obviously the price of intellectual
Liberty is eternal vigilance and
education and that means that not just
scientists but people all people who
could be called rational moderates of
all stripes must become more activist
than they are at present scientists in
particular and not just our leaders but
the rank-and-file need to engage more
fully in the body politic now the need
for this marshalling of forces is
expressed perfectly in a statement I
read of the other day which I cheerfully
borrow this is the watchword we are
called to be very active very informed
and very involved in politics the
statement is made by cardinal Dolan as
president of the United States
Conference of Catholic Bishops so
speaking as a scientist I can only say
Amen yes we are we are all called called
to be active very informed and very
involved in politics but the overlaps
between the spheres of influence of our
two sides create a small window of
opportunity for us to do so carefully
and deliberately
as colleagues and not despite our
differences as adverse s adversaries
thank you